hello and welcome to this video playing
waves hmm no I have no idea what that is
the Dominican Republic okay don't that
flag at all so Paul is going for some
and idea 3g three opening this is the
reversed pulse defense 93 here yeah I
had something like that and earlier
games with deform okay I'm glad you're
going to keep it simple and just take
this okay that's not the most exciting
options may option maybe but I think M
it should be should be ok for me okay
Bishop e3 I didn't pay much attention to
this idea but it is very very logical
for white okay yeah but should be three
after I have to do this oh it's not very
convenient but there was no other way to
keep it covered the night hmm not very
heavily yes I probably shouldn't have
taken only fault but ok hindsight is 20
10 20 2092 ok no I have no idea what the
ideas
hmm ok the night on 33 wasn't great but
I'm not quite sure where it is heading
this is the thing I understand that he
wasn't happy with the night the way is
it going okay so I think I'll just play
the normal looking moose and maybe at
this one ok wants to trade this bishop
ok
ja maybe just take it this is the the
simplest way snow the night back here
for possible night 36 yeah it's a very
equal ish position c3 I can try a 5a for
not I'm not I'm not really sure that it
leads to much and f5 is also an option
there are maybe at five ok I'll go f5
try to be a bit more active here even
though 95 might be interesting maybe
okay did not happen so maybe I'm getting
oh I get any four years subscription
getting active here all of the son of
course I'm also weakening a little bit
in my position but I don't see something
bad happening at the mode I'm ready to
play 925 ok so this I'm happy to take
will lead to week pawn on d4
which again is not not the end of the
world but certainly um yeah some
progress for black yeah this one I
cannot play Bishop c3 unfortunately
maybe I actually can but and it looks
like a weird idea okay so he has that
isolated pawn now I would you play that
and go up to five maybe I'm just double
up on it I've c5 also coming
q 35 I don't know f3 maybe we'll come
know what does it do f3 here okay so
I'll go see five okay mmm I can take
with the rook I don't know what's bad
actually I take with the pawn king of
four with the rook I think trading one
roof should be helpful here so that the
deep on is a bit more dangerous yeah the
ante I thought King to is 60 came to f6
Reggie for is somewhat somewhat annoying
but I can immediately push the porn so
activating the King em okay timewise I'm
fine that's good so let's push the
passer now okay so King to f 50 king c 1
t 2 1st e to the 1 king e5 takes takes
okay f1 g3 we win the edge pawn and it
should should win actually
so we've gone to f5 maybe that was a
little bit more precise it's not a solid
big deal though with G 30 get to the get
to the edge pawn
I should be fairly easy one let's not
try to many points k so g3 and then I'll
talk take the H pawn and then go over to
the to the Queen side
two is that important I probably just
met and fatigue or I'll do it like this
should mad at all okay so no going over
here time warning white resides Jim it
wasn't much happening actually but
somehow he gave me lots of activity this
position is just completely equal and it
stays equal four and it's not some time
c3 I wasn't sure about I wasn't quite
sure what the point is no I mean okay
you can play many things you have c4 for
example as possible one yeah just just
stay and do do nothing in particular 92
already was slightly mysterious I didn't
quite understand the point because the
night has nowhere to go okay f5 which is
actually ok what I didn't want to just
sit in so tightly do nothing the look
that worked me a little bit was 95 just
kind of ATM maybe there is a counter
play here yeah this is much more
difficulty for black in comparison for
GUI for now for example he has some
additional ideas maybe maybe this for
example a king of one that was very
passive yeah now well I think I still
think you should go 95 dr.
to this my position is just a lot better
there should be seven young this is what
it leads to this this whole thing now
I'm just pressurizing the D porn and he
sees probably losing a porn or any
answers it's tough to tough to see how
he prevents that probably you cannot do
it and yeah during the position is
probably losing the 3ds d3 d2 is
dangerous and I think geforce a
relatively best tribe yeah this is the
losing ending he's running out of moves
now after this we got this K and porn
ending which was lost and he has no he
cannot do much else and he's running out
of moves he can play a couple of
hormones but he has to get a call give
ground and I like this for example to
then yeah he's running out of moves now
him Justin fixed the pawns first and
then go with this spinning procedure so
that black wins both pawns it's often
easier to do if you have two points that
she can take than just one um yeah the
key moment in this game was probably was
here when he should not I mean I think
he shouldn't have given me that that in
the first place that I get this kind of
active play in the center of it and up
to 94 it gets it gets very very
problematic its brief Lee thinking that
this could be a move but I didn't think
this is this is right I saw this and I
wasn't sure about this because he has
group t7 and the computer actually
agrees I am a porn up at the moment but
I have to have to do this have to care
take care what this first and then jack
is the check coming now that's not good
yeah aunty why does in huge trouble okay
well thanks for watching